[Música]
la sociedad nos interpela constantemente
con preguntas del tipo porque no porque
no te casabas porque no tienes hijos
porque no te gusta el fútbol es una
pregunta un tanto pretenciosa como que
si quisiera corregir nos la vida en
causarnos una vida que en realidad
parece perdida
tengo una prima que cuando tenía 20 me
pregunta oiga bien para cuando para
cuando te casabas para cuando los hijos
y la verdad le decía no necesito casarme
no quiero tener hijos acordate que
cuando cumplas 27 te van a venir las
ganas la verdad que no llegaba llegaba
esa edad y para cuándo no
los ministros ya te lo dije a los
veintipico de inger sigo pensando igual
bueno cuando lleguen los 30 el reloj
biológico va a ser su trabajo no llegaba
a los 30 llegaron los 35 que soy y la
verdad que hay un montón de gente que
sigue esperando que me sube al club pero
nada es una decisión que tome con mi
novia en pos de hacer otras cosas y la
verdad que siempre tuve un poco de
resistencia a hacerlo lo que estaba
establecido sobre todo cuando no había
fundamentos y se hacía porque sí
[Música]
veamos esa resistencia me hizo darme
cuenta que el por qué no no era la
pregunta que el por qué no obedecía a
los mandatos culturales a lo que había
que hacer entonces de tanto escuchar el
por qué no el por qué no decidí borrarla
el no que me quede él porque él porque
desde la curiosidad desde interpelar la
realidad como los chicos de 4 años que
todo lo preguntan porque el cielo
celeste porque los perros ladran porque
si soy nena no puedo jugar con autitos
el por qué constantemente y en ese
momento me di cuenta que llené de mi
vida de porque es de la curiosidad de
querer entender la realidad y ahí es
cuando me aparece el primer síntoma de
esta enfermedad del emprendedorismo que
es el inconformismo
el inconformismo entendido no desde la
queja que tenemos todo es un posgrado en
argentina de la queja sino entendida
desde las ganas de mejorar primero
empecé conmigo me quise mejorar yo mis
capacidades intelectuales emocionales
etcétera pero después empecé a ir a lo
otro cuando ya estaba sólido entendía lo
que me movilizaba ahí empecé a observar
lo que podía mejorar en ese camino
en ese digamos esa elección yo me sentí
empoderado porque era mi personalidad sí
pero me creía torre el cambio
y la verdad que no fue gracias a la
educación primaria y secundaria es un
sistema obsoleto verticalista que
normaliza a las personas que nos hace a
todos iguales que no se estereotipa y
logra que en ese camino no fomenta la
creatividad pero sobre todo nos hace ser
obedientes ser obedientes al sistema se
acuerdan los dictados de palabras más
ridículo que eso es el dictador el libro
estaba el libro el manual pero nos
hacían dar el dictado igual copiando
porque nos seleccionaban en la tarea de
ser obedientes los dictados y en
definitiva eso lo que nos está haciendo
hacerlo en seguir los mandatos
culturales nos hace de personas aptas
para los por qué no y no para los porque
entonces en esa dinámica
yo nunca encontré a alguien que me
pregunté por qué no emprendes porque no
tienes un proyecto nunca nadie nadie me
lo dijo eso lo descubrí solo gracias a
los porque que tuve mi vida después
llegó la pregunta en que hice ahora de
nuevo porque no te buscas un trabajo
como la gente
y seguramente le han hecho a muchos de
ustedes para mi era imposible en casa no
había un mango me tenía que pagar las
fotocopias los viajes en el secundario
vendía perfumes celulares en la calle y
después pasé a trabajar de mozo en un
catering y la verdad que no era un
ambiente que me gustara estuve dos años
ahí y la obediencia del superior al
esquema de ese laburo bastante tóxico
creo que todavía tengo una cicatriz en
algún lado de la psique y bueno así que
no me quedaba otra me tenía que inventar
mi propio trabajo si no podía encajar en
ese modelo no me queda otra que
inventarme en el trabajo inventarme los
logros los fracasos los premios
y bueno y ahí descubrí mi pasión y ahí
descubrí también el primer síntoma o el
segundo pues yo dije primero
que fue no distinguir entre lunes y
domingo
lo que yo le llamo el efecto de
ocasiones queremos estar de vacaciones
que se acuestan a cualquier hora se
levantan en cualquier otra hay una
alegría constante una plenitud bueno eso
se siente ser emprendedor porque nos
moviliza la presión esa pasión nos hace
seguir adelante
pero sobre todo en contra de la libertad
pero bueno antes de hablar de la
libertad quisiera hacer un paréntesis un
poco de moda emprender todo el mundo
habla de emprender como canchero es
piola los políticos nos dicen tal
emprendan o no nos dicen qué
para ripoll
y la verdad que no fui emprendedor
siguiendo ninguno de estos de estos
mandatos lo hice porque me pregunte los
por qué y descubrí un día sin querer que
me movilizaba eso y empecé a descubrir
esos síntomas
y en toda esa dinámica
el tema del tiempo era una constante la
libertad fue lo primero que me movilizó
pero esa libertad de manejar el tiempo
de gestionar recursos de tener libertad
financiera pero el tiempo es un poco
capcioso porque en realidad gestionamos
el tiempo pero muchas veces estamos
laburando 16 horas 18 el doble triple de
cualquier trabajador pero porque no se
nos moviliza ese combustible que es que
es la pasión y en la gestión del tiempo
no es esto una dicotomía porque yo le
llamo el just in time pero no los
términos de la ingeniería industrial de
japonesa sino el justo tiempo llegamos
de pedo
ya es la facultad nos enseñan y
aprendemos a llegar justo a tiempo y los
argentinos que somos expertos en hacer
todo momento estamos apresurados en la
calle caminando
estamos siendo un poco eficientes con el
tiempo pero de la teoría anterior como
me hice mi socio bastón así bueno como
es emprender en argentina emocionante
pero sobre todo es un acto inconciencia
el contexto es cambiante adverso así que
nos tenemos que estar acomodando todo el
tiempo por eso estamos un poco
desquiciados un poco locos los
emprendedores la real academia española
define el verbo transitivo de emprender
como un acto de hacer algo determinado
siempre en cuando digamos eso amerita un
esfuerzo y un trabajo
y eso es lo que defina el emprendedor en
argentina y en el mundo claramente tengo
un amigo en costa rica que se fue hace
unos años a vivir allá un emprendedor
increíble también me llama desesperado
por la situación de argentina para que
yo le cuente bueno la verdad que si los
insumos se fueron al el dólar
está altísimo y la verdad que estamos
manejando un nivel de incertidumbre que
no sabemos cuándo nos fundimos cuando no
seguido eso le cuento que contaba con él
para abrir el mercado del caribe y de
méjico para el lanzamiento de la
bicicleta eléctrica que íbamos a lanzar
el mes siguiente y si se empieza a reír
a carcajadas de joseba que pasa que
porque está registrando y me dice es que
pasaste de decirme que estaba todo mal
al lanzar el producto a nivel
internacional estás completamente loco
bueno es que de eso se trata el ser
emprendedor que cuando esté todo mal
esté todo bien
y la verdad que cuando empecé con los
motores para bicicletas a importar de
china cuando le conté a mis amigos que
iba a hacer eso ellos me dijeron que
estuviste medio medio loco gabi ni
descuento cuando empecé con las
bicicletas eléctricas ahí se dijeron
imaginaban que la bici eléctrica era la
bici voladora de este o los voladores la
verdad que si les pregunto de todo esto
que estoy contando el ser emprendedor no
está muy bueno me parece que es
medio-bajo inauguramos 18 horas estamos
enloquecidos gestionando el tiempo pero
bueno la verdad que ser emprendedor es
hermoso es encontrar la verdad que esto
es común a todos encontrar gente muy
apasionada movilizada por lo que
realmente quiere hacer
y bueno en ese móvil de la pasión el
trabajo
descubrimos que no estamos dominados por
los porque no claramente estamos
seducidos porque es porque somos
curiosos pero en realidad me di cuenta
que estábamos enamorados de los porque
sí
el por qué si hacer las cosas el sí como
interpelaron la realidad el sí como
encontraron el sí como respuesta el por
qué si emprender porque si tener hijos
porque sí pero breve una fábrica porque
si ver fútbol de los por qués y ese es
el esa es la pregunta no el por qué no
del mandato cultural el por qué sigue
encontrar respuestas para vivir y la
verdad que en toda esta dinámica en la
cual somos todos distintos y todos
tenemos un montón de cosas que nos
movilizan
los invito a que encuentren los porque
si a la vida somos todos distintos
no hay ni blancos ni negros ni siquiera
y grises hay colores que somos nosotros
así que hoy desde acá los invito a que
encuentren sus porqués sí muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]